Era uma terça-feira, 9:12 da manhã,
quando a Renata, nome fictício,
obviamente, entrou no meu consultório,
tinha 44 anos. Ela jogou uma pilha de
exames na minha mesa. Proteína serrativa
ultrassensível em 18. Dores articulares
que a faziam mancar, uma pele inflamada,
rosácea, que nenhum creme resolvia e uma
neva mental que a impedia de se
concentrar no trabalho. Então ela me
disse com os olhos cansados: "Doutor, eu
me olho no espelho e parece que eu
envelheci 10 anos em dois". Ela tinha na
mão uma nova receita para um
anti-inflamatório mais forte. Eu olhei
pra receita, olhei pros exames dela,
então olhei para ela e fiz algo que muda
o jogo. Eu ignorei a receita por um
momento. Eu disse: "Renata, nós não
vamos apenas apagar o incêndio, nós
vamos descobrir quem está acendendo o
fósforo." E a evidência científica mais
recente aponta que o fósforo está
vazando do seu intestino pro seu sangue.
Preparem-se pro choque. Deixa pular 8
meses pra frente. A Renata, de 44 anos,
que se sentia com 60, hoje o seu PCR é
de 0,8. A pele desinflamou, a dor sumiu
e o mais importante, a neva mental
desapareceu. E como que aconteceu isso?
identificando a causa raiz que a
medicina ortodoxa estava ignorando. A
Renata não é um caso isolado. Deixa eu
contar sobre o Carlos, 61 anos,
engenheiro de Curitiba, chegou com uma
neva mental tão severa que estava
esquecendo nomes. O geriatra cogitou
Alzheimer precoce. Fizemos uma análise
de microbioma. Níveis altíssimos de
bactérias que estudos de 2024 ligam à
inflamação neural. 90 dias de um
protocolo focado em modular essa
disbiose. Hoje o Carlos está fazendo uma
pós-graduação online. A memória dele
está mais afiada. Ou então vamos falar
da Patrícia, 39 anos. Pissorias severa
cobrida um 40% do corpo. 60 dias.
60 dias de um protocolo focado em selar
o intestino e a pele dela estava limpa.
Agora deixa eu abrir o jogo com vocês.
Por que que isso acontece? E estudos
recentes, inclusive publicados em
periódicos como a Nature Aging, estão
consolidando um conceito.
Inflamaging é a palavra do momento, a
inflamação crônica de baixo grau que
acelera o seu relógio biológico. E qual
é a maior fonte dessa inflamação?
Adivinhe? Adivinhou, né? O intestino,
quando sua barr intestinal perde a
integridade, o famoso li gut, o
intestino hiper permeável, ela vaza, ela
literalmente joga fragmentos de
bactérias, o chamado LPS
lipopóisacarídio na sua corrente
sanguínea. Seu sistema imune vê esse LPS
no sangue e entra em modo de defesa 24
horas por dia. Essa guerra silenciosa é
o que aparece na pele de Patrícia, nas
juntas da Renata. E no cérebro do
Carlos, você não está só envelhecendo,
você pode estar sendo inflamado de
dentro para fora. E aqui vem a parte que
mais me frustra como médico, porque isso
não é o padrão de atendimento. Um
medicamento biológico para psorias ou
artrite pode custar de 5 a R$ 8.000 por
mês. Um protocolo para restabelecer a
saúde intestinal usa comida de verdade,
os alimentos fermentados. O foco do
sistema muitas vezes é tratar a fumaça,
a dor na junta, a mancha na pele com um
extintor químico caro. O meu foco dentro
da visão funcional é achar a fonte do
fogo. Bem, vamos ao protocolo de três
passos. Agora vou revelar a base do
protocolo que eu usei com eles. Prestem
muito bem atenção, pois isso não
substitui acompanhamento médico, mas é a
fundação da mudança. Nós dividimos em
três Rs. Tem mais RS aqui, mas vamos
falar dos principais. Remover, reparar e
reinocular. Remover, que é o passo um, é
a faxina. Por 30 a 60 dias, precisamos
parar de jogar a gasolina no fogo.
Removemos os cinco grandes agressores
inflamatórios. Glúten, a maioria dos
lácteos, especialmente os que têm dos
comuns a casa na um. Açúcar refinado,
óleo de semente, soja, canola, milho e
qualquer comida outra processada. Passo
dois, reparar.
É como se fosse o cimento. Não adianta
só limpar, precisamos tapar os buracos
da parede intestinal. O segredo que a
medina moderna esqueceu, caldo de ossos.
É uma fonte riquíssima de colágeno,
glicina e glutamina. Os tijolos para
reconstruir a barreira. Uma xícara por
dia. Se o paladar for um desafio, use-o
como base para uma sopa com cúrcuma,
cebola e alho. Passo três, reinocular os
soldados. Com a casa limpa e repada,
trazemos os soldados bons, alimentos
fermentados de verdade, chucrute,
quinchi, kefir, que pode ser de água,
pode ser de leite, de coco, por exemplo,
uma colher de sopo por dia. E precisamos
alimentar e soldados com amido
resistente. Pense em banana verde cozida
ou batata cozida e resfriada por 24
horas. Isso é alimento premium para suas
bactérias boas produzirem butirato, o
antiinflamatório natural do seu
intestino. Quando vemos a pele da
Patrícia limpar, a memória do Carlos
voltar, a dor da Renata desaparecer, a
medicina ortodoxa pode chamar isso de
remissão espontânea. Eu chamo de
fisiologia. é o corpo humano respondendo
de forma previsível quando removemos os
agressores e fornecemos a matéria-pra
reparo. A escolha é sempre sua,
continuar gerenciando os sintomas ou
finalmente decidir tratar a causa. Agora
saia do vídeo se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos.
Na comunidade fechada não tem esse
filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica.
Caso e reversão que pareciam
impossíveis, combinações of label que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários.
Live semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
com 47 protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificações
para as massas, clique em seja membro.
Não é para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados. M.